[Musique]
bonjour à tous est ravie de vous
retrouver sur lcp public sénat pour
parlement hebdo
votre rendez vous politique de fin de
semaine avec mickaël zeze mont-blanc
katia bonjour à tous alors notre invité
cette semaine olivier faur vous êtes le
président du groupe socialiste nouvelle
gauche merci d'être avec nous pour
résumer toute l'actualité de cette
semaine vous êtes également député de
seine-et-marne avec vous évidemment de
nombreuses actualités qui ont des
maillets la vie politique et
parlementaire ne fait-on de la taxe à 10
milliards d'euros qui continue
accusations mutuelles de l'ancienne et
de la nouvelle majorité on parlera
également du budget de la sécurité
sociale voté sans encombre mais toute la
gauche elle a voté contre
et puis la réforme constitutionnelle qui
semble aller sur les rails
le sénat serait prêt au dialogue avec le
président de la république et en
attendant desquels on va commencer par
le budget pas encore votée mais déjà
légèrement rectifier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le gouvernement a présenté un texte
rectificatif en urgence pour faire voter
une surtaxe entreprises objectif
compenser les 10 milliards d'euros que
l'état doit rembourser après le fiasco
de la taxe sur les dividendes instauré
par l'ancienne majorité marion châtelain
trouver 10 milliards d'euros en urgence
pour éviter un nouveau dérapage
budgétaire
c'est l'objectif de ce collectif
budgétaire mesures fiscales phares de ce
texte la création d'une surtaxe d'impôt
sur les sociétés pour 2010 est une
contribution exceptionnelle à hauteur de
5 milliards d'euros la moitié de la
somme soit demandé aux grandes
entreprises aux seuls très grandes
entreprises
320 entreprises sur les 3,4 millions
d'entreprises que coûte la france les
groupes dégageant plus d'un milliard
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires seront
soumis à cet impôt exceptionnel
le barème sera progressif jusqu'à 4
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
c'est un effort conséquent c'est un
effort nécessaire et c'est un effort que
nous avons voulu équitable en le faisant
porter principalement sur les
entreprises dans les chiffres d'affaires
sont les plus élevés cette mesure a
vocation à s'appliquer qu'une fois elle
ne remet aucunement en question le cadre
défini par le pellec 2018
l'état prendra à sa charge l'autre
moitié de la facture ce projet de loi de
finances rectificative sera examiné dans
l'hémicycle lundi prochain alors olivier
faur ça fait 5 milliards d'euros de plus
à payer pour l'état puisque a décidé de
faire porter l'effort soit entreprise à
hauteur de 5 milliards d'euros mais ça
veut dire que le budget 2010 8 qui est
actuellement n'est pas encore votée est
déjà presque caduque puisque on l'a vu
dans ce sujet le déficit public va
augmenter avec tout ça est ce que c'est
votre avis ah bah c'est un fait
02 points donc qu'ils avaient prévu 2,6
ce sera 2,8 et donc on risque
on se rapproche des 3 % mais en dessous
on souffre pas non plus mais bon on a
déjà fin on était très fétiche et c'est
que ces 3 % il ferait pas mal non trop
c'est utile de faire en sorte que
l'économie ne sont pas plombé par des
déficits est extravagant mais quand on
est sous les 3 on est dans la voilà on
est on est dans ce qu'il faut faire
on est sous les trois noms que c'est pas
la peine de chercher un bon c'est pas
mais je voyais rien sur ce sujet là qui
est un sujet qui est très compliquée que
les français doit avoir de la peine à
comprendre de quoi s'agit-il s'agit
d'une taxe qui elle-même fait suite à
une autre taxe en fait quand nicolas
sarkozy s'en va en 2012
il laisse une ardoise à la nouvelle
majorité parce que la taxe qu'il avait
mise en place sur les opcvm et une taxe
qui est annulé par bruxelles et donc va
pas bruxelles par la cour de justice de
l'union européenne et donc il laisse une
ardoise de plusieurs milliards c'est
l'héritage c'est l'héritage on a ensuite
donc une nouvelle majorité avec françois
hollande
ils y arrivent et qui doit donc ça ne
fasse ont écopé de ce qui vient de se
passer à l'époque à l'elysée il y à un
homme qui s'appelle emmanuel macron et
qui est secrétaire général adjoint et
qui supervise cette question là et c'est
lui qui est à la manoeuvre sur cet axe
où les dividendes ont qui savait tout
bien sûr qu'il savait non seulement il
savait au moment où il était à l'elysée
mais il savait quand les ministres des
finances puisque je vous rappelle qu'il
était ministre des finances jusqu'il ya
un an n'a rien dit et donc non cette
discussion là a eu lieu tout le long on
ne peut pas faire le procès à ceux qui
ont été à l'époque au pouvoir d'avoir
sous-estimé les menaces ils ont à chaque
étape consulter des juristes éminents
ils ont consulté l'appareil d'état et
compte tenu de ce qu'était la
jurisprudence de l'époque de la cour de
justice de l'union européenne
il considère à tort qu'il n'y a pas de
menace et que cette action dividende est
possible c'est donc tout photo olivier
faure le président de la république
aujourd'hui est dans le collimateur
est-ce qu'il est responsable de tout ce
qui est en train de se passer quand on
voit aujourd'hui contre votre ancien
majorité de l'actuelle majorité
c'est une guerre de tranchées sur cette
question mais c'est pas bien de trancher
il faut que chacun prenne sa sociabilité
il faut simplement que je viens il y à
une opération très particulière qui est
celle de bruno le maire qui même n'est
pas exempt de tout reproche
c'est une opération de déstabilisation
je pense qu'il ya une opération à deux
bandes et que bruno le maire à chaque
fois qu'ils utilisent ce sujet là et qui
le remet sur la table
il sait très bien que il nous amène à
rappeler que les responsabilités épisode
la république ce qui n'a pas
complètement le déranger mais vous aurez
noté que président la république
d'ailleurs là lui au même bien compris
c'était le canard enchaîné de cette
semaine est beau dans le maire n'est pas
exempt de tout reproche parce que au
moment où la taxe sarkozy a été mise en
place la première
celui qui était chargé des affaires
européennes c'était précisément mais il
a commandé donc un rapport à
l'inspection générale des finances pour
faire la lumière sur cette affaire de
taxe il dans doute pensé que c'était une
bonne idée et ça peut se terminer
comment moi je dis très bien tout ce qui
peut faire la lumière sur ce sujet moi
je ne cherche pas à ce que les uns et
les autres se déchargent de leurs
responsabilités à se déliter du côlon
précédent elle était vivante 1 il y
avait des gens qui avaient une mission
est donc même pas pour reprendre cette
vieille formule qui n'est pas toujours
servi à bonne escient mais responsable
même si pas coupable et donc il y a des
gens qui ont assumé aujourd'hui un échec
sur le plan juridique mais cet échec il
est très partagée et il faudrait pas non
plus considérer que ceux qui ont été à
l'époque aux affaires ont cherché à
masquer a détonné j'avais je veux
simplement rappeler que contre le
revenant à dresser des parties il a
provisionné 5 milliards d'euros mais est
ce que ça coûte 10 coups de plus pas se
complique donc on fera une taxe sur les
entreprises
320 entreprises oui mais ce que je dis
c'est que le gouvernement provisoire
au départ c'est très bien qu'il ya une
menace et qui donc il faut chercher à la
contenir voilà donc on une question vous
parliez du double gens que l'histoire de
du scandale d'état de bruno le maire
veut pas lier de double jeu de la part
de l'actuelle miss de l'économie c'est
quoi la suite est-ce qui peut rester
ministre de l'économie dans le
gouvernement de d'emmanuel macron dans
ces conditions moi la question et
surtout posé mon imac rond
ce que vous en avoir enfin c'est l'e3 a
enchaîné quand didier le trait de
lui-même de serpents enfin je crois que
il a est en train de cerner un de ses
ministres et le qualifie de manière
assez particulière donc c'est à lui de
voir s'il considérait le déloyauté il ya
à l'évidence des ailes de la déloyauté
de la part de ce ministre qui cherche à
fragiliser son propre président et on le
voit bien
c'est une majorité qui parfois tire à
hue et à dia
même si on cherche à sauver les
apparences mais là où il ya pas
l'affrontement direct si vous voulez on
est habitué à des frondes et que tu es
défendre direct on s'attaque là c'est
une forme non pas de fronde au sens où
il y aurait un désaccord sur le fond
mais il y a à l'évidence une volonté de
déstabilisation par bruno le maire du
chef de l'état est un jeu qui augure mal
de la suite on va passer en tout cas un
autre budget cette semaine qui a été
débattue à l'assemblée nationale fut de
la sécurité sociale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce budget a été voté mais évidemment les
voix de la gauche était contre c'est un
récapitulatif des positions de chacun de
la part de françois chevret l'assemblée
nationale a adopté le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2010 8 354% 92 contre le vote est sans
appel
avant cela il aura fallu quatre journées
de discussion dans l'hémicycle ponctuée
par des tensions autour de l'extension
de l'obligation vaccinale ou la hausse
de 1,7 point de la csg
à la sortie la majorité vente un texte
équilibré
c'est un budget assez politique parce
que y'a une hausse du pouvoir d'achat
pour les françaises et les français il
ya une hausse de la compétitivité pour
les entreprises
et puis côté santé on est on est gâté
puisqu'il ya une vraie politique de
prévention qui est mise en place à
travers les vaccins à travers la taxe
tabac à travers la taxe module est sûre
le sur les sodas le groupe l'est
républicain a voté contre
avec la hausse de la csg la droite
craint une baisse du pouvoir d'achat des
retraités
elle dénonce également l'oubli de la
politique familiale dans ce texte mais
je pense à la politique familiale pour
lequel on augmente la prestation
d'accueil du jeune enfant de 17 euros
boire coupe alors que à mon avis il
fallait privilégier la politique
familiale
une fois de plus comme pendant les cinq
années qui précèdent c'est la politique
familiale qui traque toute la gauche
s'est opposée au texte pour la france
insoumise ce projet de loi est inique
vous me les coups portés sur la santé
publique
en développant l'ambulatoire comme on va
le faire pour les hôpitaux pour faire
toujours plus d'économies
c'est toujours à faiblir et amoindrir
les soins de santé dans ce pays et puis
cette augmentation de la csg
le fait de maintenir le cic eux c'est
beaucoup de cadeau pour les riches tout
le monde paye pour les cadeaux pour les
riches
le texte arrive dans les mains des
sénateurs la semaine prochaine alors on
a entendu la france a soumise mais au
parti socialiste est ce qu on pense
également que c'est un vrai changement
de philosophie de la part du
gouvernement sur cette question de la
sécurité sociale mais on a affaire à un
prestidigitateur avec quelqu'un qui a
nouvelle façon de procéder de beaux
jours à venir un magicien tour de passe
par un magicien dire que vous avez en
fait ça c'est ma main droite
ça c'est ma main gauche alors que wendel
macron il montre la main gauche il dit
regardez on en train de d'augmenter en
fait l'occasion adultes handicapés et
puis pendant ce temps là quand vous vous
regardez la mam la main gauche il y
avait main droite qui contient
travailler à main droite qu'est ce
qu'elle a fait pendant ce projet doit se
fiant sont assistées sociales et bien
elle a augmenté le forfait hospitalier
elle a baissé la location pour les
jeunes enfants elle a contribué aussi à
faire baisser les coûts tissu social que
payent les stocks parce qu'on peut pas
dire en avant elle donne ça existe ça
peux même pas l'entendre
elle donne toujours au même et elle
prend toujours même voilà la difficulté
est donc quand on cumule la loi de
finances et la loi de finances on essaie
ce trio thé social
en réalité on a effectivement un
changement progressif de modèles on est
percé on était dans un modèle français
qui est un modèle équilibré et là on est
en train de passer à un modèle tout à
fait libérale classique donc le cernéen
sec l'anglo-saxonne on est en fait dans
une politique qui est même si ça peut
paraître très datée et ça l'est eh bien
on est sur une politique telle que celle
qu'on menait reagan et thatcher au début
des années 80 on est en fait alors je
passe un mois ça n'a pas marché ça a
creusé les inégalités ca augmenter le
nombre de pauvres ça a conduit aux
crises ça a permis de créer des bulles
en fait va tous à petit aujourd'hui que
la france se dirige vers les années
reagan et thatcher
j'étais pas que se dirigent d'icônes en
plein dedans elle en train de rentrer
dedans parce que ans
en train d'adopter des remèdes qui ont
déjà montré leur inefficacité voient
même leur dangerosité est donc là où à
un moment donné on a pensé que ce
gouvernement pouvait être et de droite
et de gauche qui pouvait être une forme
de social-libéralisme un peu sociales
impôts libéralisme là on est dans vos
réalisme et le social c'est juste un
filet de sécurité comme alfonso
gouvernements de droite et de gauche
survenue en ethnies de nos fans n'est
pas de droite et de gauche
il est de droite et de droite à
l'évidence et on a je vous pose une
question simple est ce qu'il ya une
seule mesure qui n'aurait pas été prise
par juppé ou fillon président de la
république est ce qu'il ya une feuille
de cigarette qui peut se glisser entre
ce que ces dollars
je confierais csg c'est voilà je priais
c'est kif kif bourricot mais on n'est
pas très loin
on est d'ailleurs aussi y tourner ses
des solutions budget libéral de droite
du déjà vu c'est ce que vous dites y'a
rien de neuf finalement mais moi
j'aurais tellement aimé effectivement
qu'on arrive donc on accède à un nouveau
monde et j'étais prêt j'étais prêt à ce
que on engage des rapports nouveaux
entre majorité et opposition qu'on
puisse s'en sert nombre de grands sujets
se poser sur la table et se dire on a
comment est ce qu'on fait pour
consolider le modèle français
est-ce qu'on peut arriver à quelque
chose de consensus étiez près ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui vous n'êtes plus
mais plus du prêt à tendre la main
aujourd'hui pardon à chaque fois que les
politiques iront dans le bon sens je
t'échange les approuverait il s'agit pas
d'être dans une forme de pavlovisme et
d'être systématiquement contre mais
comment aujourd'hui à prouver une
politique qui est une politique qui ne
fait place à aucun aménagement qui ne
laisse place à aucune discussion
et j'en veux pour preuve non seulement
le débat à l'assemblée
mais même y compris aux débats et ses
partenaires sociaux où on le voit bien y
compris la cfdt a été maltraité dans le
débat sur ordonnance et on voit bien que
il n'y a aucune volonté de laisser la
place à un échange et les corps
intermédiaires donc c'est un sujet alors
on va parler d'un autre sujet olivier
faur d'une réforme qui devrait vous
occuper bientôt la réforme de la
constitution du chantier lancé c'est une
promesse du président de la république
est prévue pour 2018 les sénateurs
semblent être d'accord pour négocier
regarder ce sujet la garde des sceaux
l'a confirmé ce matin la réforme
constitutionnelle aura bien lieu en 2018
regard des entretiens qui ont eu lieu
entre le président de la république le
président du sénat
et puis des entretiens que j'ai pu
moi-même à voir avec le président du
sénat au mois d'août
oui la réforme fonctionne elle aura lieu
les négociations avancent entre gérard
larcher emmanuel macron mais reste des
points de blocage pour la majorité
sénatoriale la ligne rouge et le non
cumul des mandats dans le temps voulu
par le gouvernement
s'agissant du cumul dans le temps bien
sûr qu'il faut discuter on le sait
s'agissant notamment des petites
communes
aujourd'hui on a de plus en plus de mal
moi qui viens d'un territoire rural je
le sais a trouvé des gens qui sont prêts
à s'engager si on rajoute en plus une
contrainte supplémentaire
je crains que cela ne porte atteinte
durablement à la démocratie et notamment
la démocratie de proximité
autre sujet de débat la réduction du
nombre de parlementaires
emmanuel macron veut réduire d'un tiers
le nombre de sénateurs et de députés
mais pour ce sénateur de gauche cette
mesure n'est pas nécessaire et les
départements risquent de ne plus être
assez représentés j'ai bien compris que
beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui souhaiter
une diminution du nombre de
parlementaires jeudi on n'a pas besoin
de réformes constitutionnelles pour ça à
moins de remettre en cause un certain
nombre d'autres principes mais je
m'interroge néanmoins sur l'utilité de
la chose pour moi c'est plus de la com
que réellement quelque chose qui
permettra de recréer du lien et de la
confiance entre les élus et la
population
à droite comme à gauche on s'entend sur
une chose les discussions pourront
réellement débuter une fois le texte sur
la table
olivier faur vous en tant que cheffe du
groupe socialiste nouvelle gauche à
l'assemblée jusqu'où êtes vous prêt à
aller quels sont vos ligne rouge
infranchissable
enfin des lignes rouges que vous mettez
dans la discussion sur cette réforme
moi je ne suis pas sûr que cette réforme
soit en réalité très utile et en tout
cas pas celle là c'est de la com com
deezer c'est du populisme bcbg
c'est à dire c'est à dire que on donne à
l'opinion ce qu'elle veut entendre et on
essaye de la flatter part en lui offrant
en pâture le sénat l'assemblée et en les
montrant en désignant les parlementaires
comme la source de tous les maux ça le
populisme bcbg que vous décrivez oui
parce que c'est quand même récurrent
chez emmanuel macron c'est qu'ils
désignent les élus locaux nationaux
comme finalement ce qui pose problème
aujourd'hui et donc il faudrait
évidemment les réduire en réduire le
nombre
mais ce faisant corps et on a quoi
va-t-on parvenir on va parvenir à des
parlementaires qui vont couvrir parfois
plusieurs départements quand on cherche
au contraire à rapprocher l'élu de la
population lui il va l'éloigner de deux
façons à la fois enregistrés sont très
grandes et donc vous aurez des gens qui
ne connaîtront même pas les gens qui les
ont mandatés et puis il veut faire élire
une partie de l'assemblée à la
proportionnelle ce qui va avoir pour
effet d'avoir des gens qui ne seront
plus et lui en réalité mais qui sont
désignés par leur parti et qui seront
nommés en fait à l'assemblée est donc
proportionnelle c'est pas une bonne idée
non ce n'est pas une bonne idée n'est
pas une bonne idée parce que ça détache
progressivement les élus d'un territoire
à bush pourtant fortement tendu ça
pendant là il y avait parfois de yazid
et qu'il faut les reprendre
moi je suis là je suis partisan en fait
deux choses très simples je veux que un
élu puisse avoir un territoire sur
lequel qui soit suffisamment action
important mais qui ne sont pas trop
grand pour qu'il puisse connaître
d'une certaine façon chaque commune
chaque chaque habitant c'est être
exagérément fin qu'il puisse avoir ce
lien de proximité lui permet d'avoir un
lien et trois mois je oui pendant cinq
ans depuis cinq ans je suis élu chaque
semaine en étant dans ma circonscription
en étant au contact des uns et des
autres
j ai beaucoup de choses que j'ai
découverte que j'ai apprise et des
choses que j'ai compris aussi par ce
canal là
le jour où j'aurai une circonscription
qui fera le double ou le triple qu'est
ce que je ferais je ferais je volerais
d'un endroit à l'autre je vous avais
entendu leur évoqué cette semaine qui
parlait d' emmanuel macron comme
quelqu'un qui n'aime pas la province je
résume un peu ses propos
vous êtes d'accord donc avec laurent
wauquiez non je ne suis pas d'accord
avec lui
l'excès de laurent wauquiez laurent
wauquiez qui on est quasiment à
convoquer les arguments de l'anti france
ce qui me paraît totalement extravagants
et qui est en répondent à des logiques
de campagne interne et j'imagine sur les
duels quasiment oui ça c'est absurde ce
qui ne l'est ce qui l'est moins c'est
que effectivement emmanuel macron est un
président qui est qui a été élu sans
être passé par la case élu local lui
nationale etc et donc il ne connaît pas
la mission le rôle d'un élu
il les a rencontrés que à l'elysée est
en réalité
et quand ils circulent en france
il circule entouré de caméras et il n'a
jamais fait ce que qui donne de quoi
pour vous ça c'est le signe d'une
méconnaissance et malheureusement ça se
sent
régulièrement dans les décisions qu'il
prend à dire que on sent bien que ce qui
guide sa pensée se sont finalement c'est
la doxa de bercy depuis vingt ou trente
ans et depuis vingt ou trente ans bercy
propose à chaque ministre qui arrivent
les mêmes propositions
jusqu'ici on a toujours eu des ministres
de droite ou de gauche qui ont résisté à
cette pression pas toujours mais souvent
hélas tous quittés dans les placards
ressort et un ciré voir comment père
ciel pouvoir bain bercy a pris le
pouvoir effectivement aujourd'hui jeudi
bercy après le pouvoir bercy a pris le
pouvoir
et derrière emmanuel macron c'est la
machine de versailles s'est déployé
alors prétend vos poils est avec nous
c'est aujourd'hui le journaliste qui
représente le figaro d'autres
partenaires bonjour moi je vais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
triste or that as beau bonjour olivier
faur on entre dans une période de pré
congrès au ps qui se cherche un leader
ou même votre nom circule
est ce que le prochain premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste peut être
en même temps président du groupe
président de région puisqu'il peut
cumuler ces deux fonctions non moi je
crois que dans la vie il faut faire les
choses que l'on peut faire c'est à dire
que cumuler deux trois quatre emplois ça
n'est pas possible et donc le premier
secrétaire doit être premier secrétaire
ou la première secrétaire doit être
première sera plein temps à plein temps
en tout cas c'est poser d'être
parlementaire ne peut pas qu avec
d'autres fonctions votre nom il est cité
vous avez expliqué dire que vous
aimeriez de contourner est ce que vous
avez envie quand même de briguer cette
fonction éventuellement si vos amis le
demande j'ai dit que je souhaitais que
nous puissions prendre cette décision le
plus collectivement possible et que je
ne souhaitais pas être enfin je sais que
mon nom est cité parce que par fonction
je suis aujourd'hui prise en groupe et
donc dans avec une direction collégiale
à 28 forcément moi je fais figure de
chef à une façon mais je ne souhaite pas
accaparer tous les pouvoirs moi je ne
suis pas jupiter et je ne souhaite pas
que nous ayons comme signal comme modèle
le fait d'avoir des gens qui finalement
pas d'une case à l'autre est toujours en
pensant d'abord à leur propre destin moi
je voudrais que nous pensions
collectivement et qui après avoir dit
beaucoup jeu on puisse dire à nouveau
nous et donc je préférerais qu'on ait un
autre premier ou première secrétaire
avec lequel ou laquelle je travaillerai
en équipe parce que si on veut marquer
des buts il faut une équipe il faudrait
gens qu'ils soient alors ça veut dire
d'où des ailiers il faut être mieux de
terre corps et ça veut dire vous en
savez pas vous ne serez pas le prochain
secrétaire aumessas fait ça veut dire
que l'addition sera collective que je ne
veux pas me dérober par avance si il se
trouvait que j'étais une solution pour
beaucoup mais que ce n'est pas mon choix
mon choix c'est d'être président de
groupe et de travailler avec un ou
plutôt une plutôt vu de votre jean
aujourd'hui à ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui
beaucoup de femmes de qualité au parti
socialiste est pour ça qu il en soit je
pense à najat vallaud belkacem je pense
delphine batho valérie rabault
anatolienne doré serait donc une bonne
candidate pour pense que tout serait des
bonnes candidates je pense qu'ils ont le
talent le caractère l'énergie
l'intelligence le talent une femme
plutôt une femme parce que ça serait une
façon aussi de dire que l ont aussi leur
place dans la vie politique et que nous
sommes pas allés taper du poing sur la
table la semaine dernière contre
françois hollande parce que vous avez
peut-être eu le sentiment qu'il
manoeuvrait un peu en coulisses en vue
de ce congrès il y envoie de sarko
isation le fait comme ça de recevoir
tout le monde décide est le parrain de
la gauche je crois pas que ces envois de
sarko isation mais une tentation chez
toutes celles et ceux qui ont un jour
diriger leur parti et soutien de
françois hollande qui ont même conduit à
la victoire de ne pas perdre
complètement la main et moi je crois que
le meilleur service que françois
hollande puisse rendre aujourd'hui au
socialiste c'est de ne pas chercher à
prendre la main mais de laisser cette
génération qui vient là prendre
complètement et de l'accompagner plutôt
que de la diriger vous lui demandez
aujourd'hui comme cette émission de
d'arrêter les moteurs
je crois que il a compris et je ne veux
pas être qui vous fait dire qu'il a
compris j'ai pu le lire ici ou là qu'il
avait décidé de ne pas se mêler être
plus avant du congrès vous avez pas
parlé avec les serait non j'avais parlé
directement avec lui je voulais demander
avait voulu demander d'arrêter
non je moi je suis je ne commande
personnes ça sera mieux mais je lis je
conseille à tout le monde parce que je
pense que le service qu'on à rendre aux
dualiste et y compris à lui c'est
d'avoir en fait un débat qui sont un
débat d'abord avec les militants un
débat qui donne le sentiment que rien
n'est préemptée
une petite que vous voyez certains de
ses proches par exemple stéphane le foll
qui s'activent aussi en vue du congrès
vous dites qu'ils n'ont pas compris un
peu le message des électeurs la demande
de renouveau qui s'est exprimé lors des
précédentes vagues ont très vite il
reste dix secondes
moi je veux pas dire de malaussanne le
foll parce que j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour lui et je pense qu' il vaut
beaucoup mieux que ces caricatures mais
c'est vrai que malheureusement on
incarne parfois autre chose que ce qu'on
est et donc aujourd'hui c'était fans il
incarne d'abord le gouvernement
précédent et donc c'est difficile pour
lui d'incarner la suite de nouveaux
mondes merci beaucoup
michael la semaine prochaine
[Musique]